so that's good you can prove that
probably label everything and all that
let's have a look over here because
you've got a very similar situation
again with these intercepts I haven't
drawn them in there are no triangles yet
what could I join up
what could I join up I joined up chords
over here right I'm going to join some
chords over here see there's a big one
is the little one here's the big one on
this so here and then here's a little
one okay now there are similar triangles
tucked away inside this diagram just
like there were over here where are they
where are they they're not like facing
each other like this these are the
trickier what's the relationship Michael
Doucet yeah very good
this one with PNR in it is similar to
this whole thing now how do we go about
showing that well again we only need a
pair of angles sorry a pair of pairs of
angles there's a really easy one what's
the easiest angle that's related between
both of them yeah just this guy he's in
both triangles so I'm just going to mark
immune like that that angle is common
now I only need one other angle one in a
big triangle one in a little triangle
think about the properties that you know
one fairly recently yeah I love how
you're like I'm totally got the notes
fine well tell me tell me what shape
this is you guys can alter your shape
pieces inside the circle it's a it's a
cyclic quadrilateral right you only have
two properties of that cyclic code rules
namely that the one of them is about
these angles here but that's not very
useful to you is it because this angle
here for instance is not an angle in a
triangle right but you can write this
one also to this one country what's the
relationship the exterior angle is equal
to the opposite into your angle so this
guy
exactly like those what the the second
property we just used is a shortcut to
using that one and then going angles on
a straight line okay so again we've got
our pair of similar triangles but do
watch out because they're not facing in
the same direction do you notice that
these ones are really nice it's like a
goes with D because they're both at the
top C goes with B because they're both
at the bottom but this one you can see
there there's tipped over on each other
does that make sense so for example side
P what does that correspond to in the
other triangle in the big triangle yeah
so it corresponds to these two together
because it's on the bottom it's the one
close to this angle right so I don't
have to say do it in alphabetical order
R plus s okay that's the corresponding
side so I'll try and got a big triangle
what's the other side of the small
triangle that's useful I guess we'd say
R that's the other side of the small
triangle and it corresponds to P plus Q
now what this sort of reveals kind of
handily is that there's more than one
kind of intercept right for example a
and B are intercepts on this chord but a
plus B is also an intercept it's just a
bigger one okay so in this case here
when I cross multiply have a look at
what we get we get this P P plus Q
there's a product you see that and then
here you've got R R plus s there's
there's another pair of your distance
right so in fact the wording for this is
identical for this except we're not
trying to interested in chords are we
what are these things these shapes that
we're looking at you're not chords at
all
yes the way we'd say it is product of
intercept that's the way you started off
let's let's do that because we're still
talking about intercepts that are
multiplied together so products price of
intercepts on okay how do we name these
things well they come from outside the
circle so we are going to talk about
some external point but
I just told you about this line here
what would you call it you've got a need
for this that's with an S it's a secant
it cuts right across the circle right so
I don't say products of intercepts on
secant because you've got you've got two
of them from an external point and
ironically it's actually not the
external point part of this that's the
important part it's the fact that it's
the same external point right you can't
just take secrets from wherever you like
and just like oh I've got I've got this
guy over here he's related I can have
the relationship with that guy it's
because they both come from here that
you get the similar triangles does that
make sense so Protestant intercepts on
see concerning external points say deal
same same equality relationship okay